why do why do fans tune in
because for their individual team
they want to come into that weekend
having reason to think their team's
going to be better and they don't want
to hear
your team's going to be worse they don't
want to hear that no so with that caveat
with that caveat
let's talk about some teams let's do it
bad weekends so give me one that you
think had a good no no grades just pass
fail give me a team that you think had a
pass for the weekend well listen i don't
really this one's so good i'll give it a
grade it's an eight plus i don't care i
know we don't know yet but at base level
and i've been around football a long
time to know like it's exposed somewhat
i know
man to me
again the team that won the draft if you
make me pick one team
it i'm going with the miami dolphins
just and i know you're right we'll see
how it plays out we gotta see how the
season goes but the miami dolphins
continue
to
you know show the nfl or give a lesson
in team building i mean that's really
where i just come away with it i mean
first off with the first pick with
waddle you got the two big receivers on
the outside and gaseki a tight end now
you got this guy with all these rockets
up his butt flying around the field are
you kidding me then you get the pass
rusher jalen phillips it's the only
thing they need on defense is maybe just
a difference-making edge pass rusher oh
wait they got the guy that's went to
college in their city so i'm sure they
know really a ton about him and so they
get him javon holland the safety there
you know just another
i think the thing that i like about it
is they're kind of like mike a lot of
their guys even though we don't know how
good they're going to be i can sit here
and tell you i don't they're not going
to be bad they're going to be
contributing to their football team
holland was a really good safety one of
the best in the draft you get liam
eichenberg an nfl ready right now left
tackle from notre dame who can play
guard and has played guard so now they
got him contributor high-end backup
right off the back uh right off the bat
and then hunter lawn hunter long is a
big blocking
you know tight end who has a little
value in the pass game so i just to me
the way they thought out the draft the
picks they made
you know a little bit of you know
aggressiveness and hey we'll take a
chance on a jalen phillips we think the
work
the risk is worth the reward there and
all of that
i was just blown away by the dolphins
draft
i wonder how aggressively they tried to
trade out of the six spot though because
we had heard that they wanted to and of
course more teams would like to trade
down
than trade up and you have to find
someone who's willing to make that move
and you look at how the board played out
no one was really trying to get that
high the eagles wanted to get back into
the top ten to jump the giants and get
devonta smith a guy that many thought
the dolphins would take at six but i
just wonder it could have been even
better because maybe they could have
fallen down a few spots still gotten a
high end receiver
and picked up more draft capital that
could have been used this weekend or
next year when the 2022 draft rolls
around i'm going to give some praise
here to the falcons for a couple of
reasons i've mentioned in the past
that
the falcons just kept their mouths shut
they they said all the predictable
things that you're supposed to say it's
not like they went full-blown new
england patriots and gave us nothing
but they they didn't get into this
public
monologue of what are we gonna do with
the fourth overall pick are we gonna go
quarterback i mean they kind of shut
that down before it could take on a life
of its own remember the reporting that
there was a split between right now the
new gm who wanted a quarterback and
arthur smith the head coach who wanted
to stick with matt ryan they slammed the
door on that a few weeks ago and it
never came back dude the dude at the
laptop is it kind of look at the guys
everybody else is celebrating and
young guys in his phone isn't that a
perfect snapshot of life in 2021
the old people are actually living in
the moment and the young guys living in
his phone anyway i got to give him
credit for
for
squashing that idea that they're going
to replace matt ryan not that they could
have taken trey lance anyway because he
went number three they go with kyle
pitts
they you know their draft is all about
trying to make chicken salad out of a
bad cap situation
and and hoping that maybe they can keep
matt ryan around i mean he's 36 has he
turned 36 yet i think he has i think
yeah 36 this month um he's still got
football left in him he's still got
plenty left i interviewed him before the
season started he's not a guy who's you
know in that well this is my last year
or two and uh i think that they decided
instead of trying to find the next
franchise quarterback
let's just keep the one that we have
yeah that's right and let's work on
putting some pieces around them even if
they subtract julio jones and i still
think that that's on the table but i
just feel like top to bottom it was
about
it was about turning the page
on this mud that they've been spinning
their wheels in ever since 28 to 3. and
let's go forward and we don't have to
change quarterbacks to go forward we can
put new pieces around him and try to do
it that way yeah no i i mean listen we
talked about this a lot before the draft
that made sense i mean again the day and
age we're in right now 36 is just not an
old quarterback you shouldn't even
you shouldn't even be looking to replace
a guy that's like played like matt ryan
has the last two years so that that's
where i think that's like uh
you know
a good move by the organization
why give something away
and do that when it's still really good
and give it away for something where
you're not sure how good it's going to
be we hope we think we don't know i mean
that that is where i think it is the
wise move there that you can always make
a move for the quarterback in the future
you don't know what's going to happen we
just saw a team go from 12 to 3 this
year and make those type of moves so you
can do what you got to do when the time
comes to get it done there's no doubt
about it so i'm i'm with you with the
falcons and their logic there
you know i i don't want to go too far
down this rabbit hole but when you think
of what the 49ers gave up to go from 12
to 3. just remember that when teams are
circling the drain in december and we
talk about tanking that there is real
value
in finishing you know as bad as you can
once you know it's done there is value
because then you don't have to give up
multiple first round picks to get in
position to get that quarterback you may
want by the way matt ryan turns 36 may
17. he is still
35 okay 35 for now yeah for another two
weeks so enjoy your last two weeks matt
of 35 36 is coming end of career not
coming all right give me a guy give me a
team that that that you think
had a bad draft that had a c plus c plus
draft because that's the lowest the
lowest grade that was given out or
something that made you just kind of
scratch your head and say what the hell
are they thinking i i think the new
orleans saints might be the one that i
think that i mean it's hard to go
negative you know but first off because
you judge a lot of it on the first and
second round a lot of those are the top
players you watch but hey peyton turner
at the end of the first round no i mean
i that was a shocker to me i did not
like i like the player of peyton turner
i did not at any point in my evaluation
think he was a first-round type talent
and i'll throw that on top of their
second round pick and pete warner from
ohio state too you know again like solid
player but to me not the athlete or the
specimen to
be a second round pick so that those
were head scratchers to me i hope i'm
wrong i mean i i know that but yeah i
mean with peyton turner i just felt like
there was more impressive people
on the board joe tryon from washington
who the bucks took you know rousseau uh
from miami of course him as well just
the potential and the size of that human
being everything there so i think the
the saints one would be one that yeah
kind of uh was a little bit of a head
scratcher to me their first two round
their first two picks especially
you know we had heard so much about the
saints trying to trade up right into the
top ten
and the the thinking was they just got
trapped in no man's land there at 28
right and they took peyton turner
although if you're looking for a
defensive end i mean gregory rousseau
that guy is a giant and yeah i tend to
gravitate a little more to the guys
we've gotten to know during the process
but six foot seven the picture of him
shaking the hands of sean mcdermott and
brandon bean it is jarring how large
that human being is he had 15 and a half
sacks in his one year playing and they
left him on the board for peyton turner
instead so yeah i agree with you that
was a little bit of a head scratcher you
know for me um
i hate to keep bringing it back to the
packers
but
yeah it's okay the whole weekend was a
disaster for them now yeah now
you know they they finally did draft a
receiver
named a rogers which is just kind of
strange right and you just wonder did
they think about not taking the guy
because
they were going to be stuck with those
comparisons but
the way they handled the draft last year
how many teams could we point to saying
the way you handled last year's draft
ended up clouding in a very negative way
the perception
of this year's draft
um and and look i can't be
overtly critical of any of the guys they
they picked
uh you know you got help on the
offensive line yeah that's a good pick i
have a quarterback one way or the other
uh eric stokes we don't know how he's
going to pan out he wasn't regarded as
one of the top defensive that was a
little weird to me
yeah yeah um but you know
i i would have liked to have seen a
receiver before round three i i i i
almost feel like there's a certain
amount of intransigence that happens
with the packers now because they don't
want people telling them how to run
their team they don't want their
quarterback telling them how to run
their team they don't want anyone
telling them how to run their team and
they almost resist drafting a receiver
in round one
because they don't want to give in
to everyone who's saying why aren't you
drafting a receiver in round one yeah i
mean it you know
there seems to be some sort of
stubbornness there to a degree
uh now listen the formula in which they
believe in and they are you know
steadfast to stay with hey it produces
results there's no doubt they've they've
been relevant it's something good
there's no doubt about it the problem is
like we like you know just because we're
on this now they just never deviate from
it never you know it's like yeah we can
have the conversation and go hey they've
been really good for 20 something years
now or you could have the conversation
and go wait they've had two of the five
greatest quarterbacks in the history of
the sport and they've won two super
bowls one with each that that to me is
not good enough when you lay it down
like that but yeah i mean uh
you're right the whole weekend was weird
for the packers and it wasn't like i
came away going like oh wow you know
they killed it they did a good job i
think the center you know good player
out of ohio state that's good we know
they needed that but when you talk about
the corner there at the end of the first
yeah a little controversial there to me
in my opinion i think there was better
ones to be had in the second round you
know his teammate from georgia the kid
the cowboys took i would have taken them
but we'll see how that plays out um and
amari rogers is a good little player
definitely but i don't think that's
going to like
you know uh what do i want to say feed
the appetite of rogers and make them
feel like all better now or anything
like that it doesn't matter no oh that
the the the issues are so much bigger
than whether or not they picked a
receiver round one two three four it
doesn't matter anymore it's it's over
that that's the reality that's gonna
sink in it's over and
it would be so awkward at this point for
him to
wha what would they even begin to do
whatever they would have to do to get
him to swallow his pride and play for
the packers again they're just not going
to do
so it's just a question of how this
divorce unfolds does he not play for
them and pay them back a ton of money
does he go host jeopardy if he's offered
that gig do they finally throw their
hands in the air and trade him does it
happen during the season like it did
with carson palmer i think that's how
that all plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports